Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and Agents of
SHIELD totally just took a field trip to TAHITI.
There was a temporary resolution to the Skye
cliffhanger and two more characters from the
comic books were featured.
There was also something of a reveal at the
end.
So first let’s talk about our top 5 WTF
moments, then I’ll tell you some of my theories
of what that big reveal was at the end and
then my review.
In case you’re finding me for the first
time, usually Tuesdays are dedicated to Marvel
videos.
I usually do Agents of SHIELD when there’s
a new episode and a Marvel Movie video.
This week was a little different just because
there were some important trailers to do.
But let’s talk some TAHITI.
Careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
the episode.
But Number 5 - Melinda May frees the beast
all over Quinn.
This is ABC so I didn’t expect her to give
him the business to badly but it was still
pretty fun.
They hadn’t done much with the Quinn character
after they captured him.
I would have thought Ward would have been
the first one to smash his face.
They whole moment was really used just to
get Coulson to figure out that the Clairvoyant
wanted Quinn to shoot Skye so that Coulson
would take her to the TAHITI place and give
her whatever super serum he received.
Plans within plans.
This really only sucks if you’re Skye because
shooting her was a red herring.
It had nothing to do with killing her.
Number 4 - Bill Paxton guest stars as Agent
Garrett from the comics.
It’s always fun to see people from the comics.
In the comics Garrett is mostly known as a
former SHIELD agent who was turned into a
cyborg.
Like the same type of thing that happened
to Mike earlier this season.
Before he became a SHIELD agent he was guilty
of all kinds of awful stuff.
Had he been in the DC Universe he would have
been recruited for the Suicide Squad.
That’s how bad he was.
Eventually he even was flagged as a potential
future Avenger.
All I could think of when he was on screen
was Aliens when the Colonial Marines were
searching for Aliens.
Which is actually kind of relevant to one
of my other top moments.
Number 3 - TAHITI isn’t such a magical place
after all.
So this was a bit misleading.
Because TAHITI turned out to be a special
facility with a miracle drug.
So it kind of was a magical place.
I had hoped that they would find more teasers
there than they did.
But a couple of things we learned were that
Nick Fury is a level 10 agent.
Meaning it probably stops at 10.
More to the fact, WTF does TAHITI stand for.
It’s an acronym, so let’s try to solve
that rubix cube in the comments.
Speaking of which, who else got a tesseract
vibe from the computer database Fitz and Simmons
used to find the location.
It’s a SHIELD blacksite, meaning there are
probably more hidden illegal underground bunkers
like this all over the world.
The Winter Soldier is going to deal with some
of these secrets within secrets that Coulson
dealt with this week.
Number 2 - The regenerative serum they gave
to Skye.
The whole conceit before it was revealed to
us was that the serum was what made Coulson
go crazy and want to die during his regeneration.
That’s why he didn’t want them to give
it to Skye.
If you didn’t catch it, Coulson and the
team talk about how she didn’t make any
noise when they gave it to her.
Meaning she didn’t have a violent reaction
to it like coulson.
I’ll talk more about that in just a sec.
and my Number 1 moment - The blue alien inside
the TAHITI room.
So many WTF things about this, so let’s
start with the biggest part.
Who is he?
Well Marvel doesn’t legally have rights
to use the Kree and the other possibilities
are Frost Giant and Centaurian.
The Centaurian’s are who the race Yondu
from Guardians of The Galaxy are.
He’s being played by Michael Rooker and
as you can see.
The person in the tank does look larger than
that.
So I really do think it’s a Frost Giant.
It would certainly fit with all the other
connective Thor tissue the show has had this
season.
So what does it mean that Skye didn’t flip
out when she took Frost Giant blood.
She has Frost Giant DNA.
Who else do we know in the Marvel Universe
that looks like a normal person but is really
a Frost Giant...Hmmm…Loki of Course.
He’s 100 percent Frost Giant but was like
the runt of the litter.
So just because Sky is potentially a Frost
Giant doesn’t mean that she’s related
to Loki.
But hopefully we’ll find out.
Isn’t it just so curious that the next episode
is another Thor-based episode with Lady Sif
and Lorelai?
There are no coincidences.
My Loki Clairvoyant theory is starting to
seem less crazy though.
But alternately, it’s totally possible that
Marvel worked out the legal mumbo jumbo to
use the Kree and that’s who it is.
It would be a bit left field seeing as we
haven’t seen the Kree anywhere in a Movie
yet and introducing them would be a huge deal.
But let me know what your vote is.
Was the blue alien a Frost Giant or was it
Kree?
Remember, it was really just the upper half
of an alien.
Overall I gave the episode a solid B plus.
Even though they showed a freaking alien,
the episode had it’s lowest ratings all
season.
We can probably blame the olympics for that,
but the story was great.
The only thing that I didn’t like was the
Hospital scene.
It felt like they were trying to do a mini
episode of ER or Grey’s Anatomy.
I don’t like hospital shows if you can’t
tell.
Bill Paxton was great as a sleazebag SHIELD
agent from the comics.
And as much as people are down on the show
I think that once they reveal the truth behind
whatever the mystery of Skye’s parentage,
The Clairvoyant and Coulson’s mystery serum
are the show is going to exist in that meta
comic book place that everyone wants it to
be in.
Like I said next week Lorelai is even bringing
magic into the world, the world of SHIELD
so to speak.
I have some suspicions about the nature of
magic in Thor as Loki practices it too.
One of the cool things we learned about that
from Dark World was that Frigga, his mother
played by Renee Russo, was the one who taught
him magic.
I’ll be really interested if it turns out
Skye really is part Frost Giant because it
provides some interesting opportunities to
mirror Loki’s narrative.
Finding out you descend from your sworn enemies,
but you made a home with a different race
of beings.
Loki obviously went a little nutters, but
he is named after the god of mischief.
In other news, lot of awesome comic book bombs
being dropped on Arrow.
If you’re not watching it yet, they’re
bringing on the Suicide Squad and they just
teased Harley Quinn for the next episode.
I’ll be talking about that tonight.
Be sure to subscribe to get that video.
Also feel free to leave suggestions for my
next Marvel Tuesday video.
Mostly I like them to be movie related.
Right now click here to learn all about my
Loki Clairvoyant Theories, it’s still totally
up for debate.
and click here to learn about my top 5 choices
for the next Captain America movie.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!